Marvel famously plays their cards close to
the vest when it comes to keeping story details
secret...both to avoid spoilers and to keep
fans guessing.
But the studio has revealed some unexpected
characters set to appear in its next big film.
Here's a look at some of the most surprising
characters confirmed for Avengers: Endgame.
And, obviously, some major potential spoilers
ahead.
Portrayed by Tilda Swinton in 2016's Doctor
Strange, the Ancient One was Stephen Strange's
mentor who taught the eventual Sorcerer Supreme
everything he knows about magic and the mystic
arts.
In the film, it's revealed that she'd been
using dark magic to lengthen her life.
"She draws power from the dark dimension to stay alive"
That's not true I've seen the rituals, worked them
out."
Soon after, in a savage battle with villain
Kaecilius, the Ancient One is mortally wounded
and dies.
But not before a final heart-to-heart with
Strange via astral projection.
While death isn't always the end of the road
in superhero movies, the images of the Ancient
One's vanishing astral projection seemed as
final an outcome as one can receive in the
MCU.
That's exactly why many fans were surprised
to see Swinton's name on Endgame's IMDb page.
Following her death, Doctor Strange wielded
the artifact known as the Eye of Agamotto,
which was revealed to be the Time Stone.
The Ancient One's reappearance has fueled
fan theories that time travel will play a
major role in Endgame.
In the first act of Infinity War, Wong joins
the fight against the invading Black Order.
Once Doctor Strange is kidnapped, however,
Wong abruptly exits the remainder of the film's
action to protect the Sanctum Sanctorum.
While Wong's fate post-snap is never fully
revealed, the actor has confirmed his participation
in Endgame.
Assuming this means that Wong is alive and
well, this character could wind up being surprisingly
crucial to
the plot.
"Wong you're invited to my wedding."
Doctor Strange is conspicuously left out of
the confirmed cast for Endgame.
When last we saw him in Infinity War, he was
disintegrating to dust while also hinting
at a larger plan.
In Doctor Strange, Wong was the keeper of
the mystical library in Kamar-Taj and was
responsible for schooling Strange on the nature
of the Time Stone encased within the Eye of
Agamotto.
As perhaps the last hero standing with in-depth
knowledge of the Infinity Stones, and significant
experience wielding the Time Stone, Wong may
be the one to bring Benedict Cumberbatch back
to the Endgame call sheet after all.
Remember back in Iron Man 3 when Tony Stark
wound up in the garage of young Harley Keener?
"Freeze.
Don't move.
You got me."
While the character served the narrative of
Iron Man 3 and comedic sensibilities of director
Shane Black, what place could this kid now
a teenager possibly have in Endgame?
With rampant speculation that Endgame could
be Robert Downey Jr.'s final MCU appearance,
certain theories suggest that Keener could
make an appearance for Tony Stark's funeral.
Others theorize that Stark could be looking
to pass the torch, and perhaps Keener could
be in line for the Iron Man mantle.
Nearly every one of the Guardians of the Galaxy
perished in Infinity War only Rocket remains
of the core group.
Star-Lord, Drax, Mantis, and Groot were all
taken in the culling.
It seems the Infinity Gauntlet affected an
unfair percentage of Guardians until you remember
that Star-Lord totally blew it on Titan.
"No you didn't"
Maybe that's why he's the only one of these
characters not listed on Endgame's IMDb page.
Mantis, Groot, and Drax are all confirmed
to be appearing according to that cast list.
Gamora was also killed by Thanos in Infinity
War, though not by the snap instead, she was
offered as a sacrifice on planet Vormir by
Thanos in order to acquire the Soul Stone.
We do see Gamora one more time in Infinity
War, however.
Once Thanos has completed his goal of wiping
out half the life in the universe with the
Infinity Gauntlet, he appears in a dreamlike
dimension confronted by a young Gamora.
The scene is bathed in an eerie orange light,
the same color as the Soul Stone.
Speaking to children at Iowa City's City High,
co-director Joe Russo confirmed that this
scene actually takes place within the Stone
— or perhaps a pocket dimension created
by it.
If Gamora is in this purgatory-like place
within the Soul Stone, is it possible that
the other dusted characters are also within
the orange realm?
Despite their apparent deaths in Ant-Man and
the Wasp, current and former Wasps, Hope and
Janet Van Dyne, are both listed on Endgame's
IMDb, though notably, Hank Pym isn't on the
list.
According to Peyton Reed, who directed Ant-Man
and the Wasp, his film's timeline was left
intentionally ambiguous.
"We liked the idea of the structure where,
in true Ant-Man style, everybody has closure
and everything's tied together and almost
in too neat of a bow at the end.
Then to BANG — give the audience a gut punch
right after the main credits.
That felt like our movie's tone and the way
of dealing with that."
In that credits sequence, just before Scott
hops into the Quantum Realm, Janet gives him
a potentially loaded warning:
"And don't get sucked into a time vortex.
We won't be able to save you,"
Could Scott Lang stuck in the Quantum Realm
possibly find a way to access different points
in time using a vortex?
Actor Frank Grillo has confirmed that Crossbones
makes an appearance in Endgame.
The boney bad guy hasn't appeared in the MCU
since the opening sequence of 2016's Captain
America: Civil War, when he detonated a bomb
on himself.
"And you're coming with me"
Speaking during a podcast interview with UFC
Unfiltered, Grillo said:
"He makes an appearance in the next Avengers
movie, but it's a flashback."
What's interesting here is Grillo's use of
the term "flashback."
Crossbones' appearance may very well be a
standard narrative flashback.
But it could also be a lot more, given all
the time travel rumors surrounding not only
the Time Stone, but Ant-Man and The Wasp's
mid-credits sequence that leaves Ant-Man stuck
in the Quantum Realm.
We all know Spidey is due back for his second
solo MCU film in Spider-Man: Far From Home.
However, considering that the last time we
saw Peter Parker he wasn't feeling so good,
it's still kind of surprising to see his name
listed with the confirmed cast.
Evidently, something gets Peter Parker back
from the great beyond in time for his field
trip in Far from Home.
But fans believe that the trailer for Far
from Home hints at the death of another character
in Endgame: Tony Stark.
Not only is Stark completely absent from the
Far From Home trailer, but some say Spider-Man's
decision not to bring his Spidey Suit with
him on his trip is further evidence of Iron
Man's demise, and Peter's need to get some
distance from that grief.
Of all of the terrible downfalls that occured
in Infinity War, perhaps nobody had a harsher
demise than Wanda Maximoff, a.k.a. Scarlet
Witch.
Wanda uses her powers to pull the Mind Stone
from the Vision's head and destroy it.
However, Thanos spoils her sacrifice by using
the Time Stone to rewind time and just get
the stone anyway.
On top of that, the snap turns Scarlet Witch
to dust just a few moments later.
Despite all that, Elizabeth Olsen is slated
to reprise her role in Endgame.
According to Olsen, her situation won't improve.
Speaking on a panel at ACE Comic Con in Chicago,
Olsen cryptically warned that it was only
going to get worse.
Sebastian Stan's Winter Soldier and his friendship
with Chris Evans' Captain America has been
an emotional fulcrum for the MCU narrative
in recent years.
In Captain America: Civil War, the fight between
Cap and Tony was much deeper and much more
personal than politics.
It took the bigger debate of the Sokovia Accords
and boiled it down to fighting for the soul
of Bucky Barnes.
With Bucky reduced to ash in Infinity War,
how does Sebastian Stan find himself back
for Endgame as Winter Soldier?
Appearing on The Late Late Show with James
Corden, the host asked Stan if he could explain
how he came back for Avengers: Endgame.
Stan had a coy reply for Corden:
"Bucky's dead.
Happy New Year.
That's it.
That's all I got."
Darn these Marvel secrets!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.